hey vsauce
michael here when something becomes part
of the past
can it ever truly be experienced again
obviously my beard will grow back
but it won't be the same beard and it
won't be on
the same person it will be on a slightly
older
different michael but of course the
bearded michael of the past isn't
completely gone
no he still exists in our minds as a
memory
and in the form of records of the past
like images and video
hi i'm the slightly older different
michael you heard about
i am 130 days older than that guy
wow 130 days you know it really doesn't
seem like it was that long ago
just as an optical illusion is a
distortion of our sense of sight
a temporal illusion is a distortion of
our sense of time
some seem small like how a minute spent
waiting in line
can seem to take forever but an entire
day with friends can just fly by some
seem deeper like the uncanny feeling we
get from recordings that make people
from long ago
seem more real than usual or the strange
way
time seems to sneak by for example the
songs i liked as a kid
wannabe m-bop semi-charmed life are as
old to kids born today as the literal
oldies were when i was born
how could that be true am i really that
old now
i mean i shouldn't be surprised i know
how time works but yet
i don't far from being just mistakes
these illusions are the edges of another
dimension of space-time
not one given to us by physics not one
given at all but one
made by our minds let's begin
with the different ways there are to
feel
time actually sitting down and
consciously
tuning into the passage of time as it
happens is called feeling time
prospectively you can't do that to time
that's already happened
except you can if i were to ask you
without looking to guess how long you
have been
watching this video you'd probably be
able to come up with a guess
you were reasonably confident in well
you arrived at that guess
by feeling time retrospectively
by measuring it as it appears in your
memory
now with that in mind we are ready to
approach our first illusion
the holiday paradox a four
hour delay at the airport before your
holiday can feel
unbearably long while it's happening but
once you arrive
an exciting day at your destination can
seem to fly by
those feelings are all prospective
timing
a week later retrospectively the delay
often feels like a blip
in your mind and the day of sightseeing
feels like a much longer
bigger part of your life these are the
long short
and short long patterns of felt time
which one you feel depends on whether
what you are doing is
empty or full an empty activity is
monotonous unstimulating
unimportant to you whereas a full
activity
is packed with sensations novelty
significance context change
and challenge now i experienced this
during my three days in isolation
while i was there time dragged very
very slowly a fear i have right now is
that it's just friday
and there's still a lot of time left
but now years later it's hard to believe
that i spent
three full days in that room jeez
seems like something i barely did well
it's believed that perspective time
feels fast when an activity is
full because you're not busy thinking
about time if you're not attending to it
you're busy with something else well you
won't notice how much time has passed
but to understand retrospective
illusions let's ask a different question
does time speed up as we get older many
of you may
feel the same way looking back my
childhood feels like it lasted
so long but my 20s went by
faster and my 30s are going by even
faster than that
a popular explanation is the proportion
theory
it suggests that time seems to speed up
as we age
because each new unit of time that we
live is smaller
relative to all the time that came
before
the year you lived as a nine-year-old
was 10
of your entire existence up to that
point but when you're 30
another year is just 3 percent more life
studies have found little evidence that
weeks months or even
years are retrospectively remembered as
passing faster by those who are
older but decades yes
and while it's true that the older we
get the faster we tend to think the last
10 years went by
that only appears to be the case until
about the age
of 50. after that the speed of decades
appears to plateau
a leading explanation is that how long a
duration
feels depends on how many things in it
can be recalled
in my normal life lots of different
things happen every three days
but during the three days i was in
isolation so little happened that i have
few distinct memories from it my mind
sees that emptiness and perceives that
it was brief
so perhaps a decline in new experiences
and rapid novelty
as we age means fewer events our brains
decide to commit to memory
so then looking back because there are
fewer distinct memories from more recent
decades we assume
they were shorter you know reflecting on
all of this it's striking just how many
moments
are forgettable john koenig the author
of the dictionary of obscure sorrows
calls the awareness of how few days are
memorable
olika over time our specific daily
perceptions of what happened
conglomerate into generalized ideas
about how things were
themes moods the big picture what was
perceptual becomes conceptual and
concepts are good
they lower cognitive load by wringing
out details leaving us with the broader
lighter just but they can also obscure
reality
which brings us to our second distortion
chronological
illusions the world of our experience
is not made of distinct entities it's a
continuity of fuzzy overlapping blobs
and we impose
concepts on it for example is a hot dog
a sandwich
is cereal soup how many holes does a
straw have those aren't questions about
reality there are questions about words
we made up
periodization is the chopping up of time
into contrived pieces like
the stone age the renaissance the 80s
the 90s but here's the thing when
did the 80s or 90s really happen i mean
mathematically
they refer to years that have eights or
nines in the tens place
but conceptually well it's not like on
january 1st
1980 people woke up and were like whoa
whoa whoa
guys it's the 80s quick everyone change
your clothes
concepts say too much and too little
facts that expose their imperfections
are perennial favorites on social media
i made an entire video about them in
fact but what hasn't been discussed yet
is the mechanisms by which we allow them
to do their
dirty work let's dig in and see what we
can find
if i asked you to lay down on the floor
of a windowless clockless room
and get up after you thought a minute
had passed
you'd probably do a pretty good job but
if i asked you to get up after you
thought
10 years had passed that'd be hard
we lack an ability to sense and grasp
long periods of time also we can't
remember everything that happens
so instead of comprehending history's
correct scale and structure
i believe that our minds often just use
how we think
about past events to place them relative
to each other
in time one way we do this is through
what i call the conceptual comparison
heuristic
a technique whereby we use the
similarity
of elements in our conceptions of things
to judge
their temporal distance if our
concepts of two things suggest wildly
different times it's natural to assume
that a lot
of things happened between them and if a
lot happened
the duration separating them must be
large
alternatively if our concepts aren't too
different
the time between them must be bearer of
events and so it feels brief
it's not a bad strategy but
tyrannosaurus died out 66 million years
ago
and when t-rexes began roaming the earth
stegosaurus had
already been extinct for more than 80
million years
to a t-rex the stegosaurus was even more
ancient than we think
t-rexes are here's another example when
we think of marilyn monroe we think of a
young woman
old hollywood mid-century glamour
americana black and white
when we think of the queen of england we
think of an old woman
in color in england and news headlines
because those conceptions are quite
different we mentally place each woman
in a different time
so it can come as a surprise to learn
that they were both born
in the same year similarly it can be
surprising to learn that anne frank
and martin luther king jr were also born
in the same year
and if they were alive today they would
both be
younger than the queen of england when
harriet tubman was born
thomas jefferson was alive and when she
died
ronald reagan was alive this is
surprising to many of us because our
concepts of these people are anchored
to them as adults but harriet tubman
was a four-year-old when thomas
jefferson died and when she died
ronald reagan was a two-year-old far
from just being amusing chronological
illusions can often have
teeth america can feel like an idea
fixed long before any of us by the
overwhelming bulk of events that came
before
but barbara walters has been alive for
more than a third of america's entire
history
and if you were 25 you have already
lived through and been a part of more
than 10
of america's history chronological
illusions may
also be caused by what i call the
construal
level heuristic a technique whereby we
place things in time
based on whether we construe them
concretely or abstractly
in social psychology construal level
theory describes how
abstract and concrete thinking relate to
psychological distance
that is how distant something seems as
opposed to how distant it actually
is now unsurprisingly it's been found
that people tend to think about things
that are psychologically distant
more abstractly but studies have also
found that if people are asked to think
about an event abstractly
they'll consider it more distant than if
asked to construe it concretely
this may explain why things can turn out
to be longer ago
or more recent than we thought if an
event recedes especially quickly from
relevance or
is suddenly replaced in our daily
thoughts by other more
urgent events unconnected to it our
minds may shift its construal to a
higher level making it
feel further back in time than it really
is conversely
if attending to the low level details of
an event continues to be
important our construal level heuristic
will make it feel
closer in time than it really is our
third illusion of time comes from the
fact that
time is always moving forward
because of that the psychological
distances we feel towards things should
also always be changing
but not all of them do the belief that
your place
in time is stable is what i call
the chronostatic illusion tim urban
pointed out that it is now the case
that jurassic park forest gump the lion
king
were all released closer to the moon
landing
than today as a person who remembers the
lion king being brand new
and remembers feeling at that time that
the moon landing was
old this is all very weird the lion king
seems so much more recent than the moon
landing ever did to me
the conceptual comparison heuristic
places them far apart
my concept of the 90s will probably
always stray from my concept of the
present
a little less than it should because the
90s and now have something in common
that the 90s and the 60s never did or
will
me also my construal level of the lion
king may resist becoming abstract
because
the lion king continues to evolve
and happen the mechanisms i use to place
things in time have sunk
hooks into the lion king creating a sort
of
chronostatic cling that fools me into
believing it's more near
the music that was new when i was young
has also been tethered in my mind to the
idea of
new stuff only us kids get even as it
has
actually been drifting away as far away
as the stuff
i used to think was far a chronostatic
illusion is spectacularly broken when
you realize that you have become as
old as your parents were when you were
born
it doesn't always seem quite right they
came first and as such
should always be older but suddenly
you're aware of a way in which they
aren't your age gap with people in the
past
is not static your parents keep getting
older
right along with you but the people they
were
don't this can lead to empathetic
realizations
they weren't any wiser or more folded
into the world then
than you are now considering the
temporal perspectives of other people
leads us to a fourth distortion the
chronocentric
illusion the belief that our own
relationship to
time is the best or only frame of
reference
or that it's more important and more
real
than any other my grandparents used to
tell me about how when they were kids
they didn't have television and i always
thought that sounded so weird i mean
obviously i knew it was true but like
what the heck did they do with their
free time
it wasn't relatable at all people back
then must have been
so different not real in the same way i
was
but i remember a time before the
internet before mobile phones and it
wasn't that weird
the internet and cell phones are still
in my mind an additional thing we now
have
but for my daughter they will be what
we've always had
and when i tell her about a time when no
one had the internet and didn't even
know they needed it
it will likely sound to her just like
the old stories
i heard about growing up with no tv and
that's bizarre my grandparents childhood
was weird it was the olden days mine was
totally normal
protagonist syndrome is the belief that
you
are the main character of the universe
recognizing that you aren't is what john
koenig famously called
saunder the realization that other
people
like that stranger over there you will
never see again have
full lives just as important and
consuming to them
as yours is to you i'd like to add
to protagonist syndrome the concept of
above syndrome
abovo means from the egg from the very
beginning
in literature it describes a story that
begins at the start
ab ovo as opposed to in the middle in
medius res
ab ovo syndrome is the belief that the
movie of the universe began
when you began that the times of your
life are
the plot and contain the climax and that
everything before you
was just backstory everything after
merely sequels
when you realize that that's not true
that you were not born
ab ovo but in medius res that you'll die
before the credits and that everyone who
has ever lived was a fully fleshed out
protagonist in their own minds
that feeling is what i call chrono
saunder
saunder not just for people over there
but for people
over then overcoming the chronocentric
illusion
isn't always easy it doesn't help that
people from the past
are finished unlike us who still have
choices to make
they tell the same story over and over
again
they're also separated by barriers made
of their own
evidence the world wasn't actually black
and white in the past and it didn't
suddenly become vertical
in the present obviously we all know
that but the arbitrary
technical properties of a times
recording media can
influence our perception of the past
nonetheless
if silent films didn't look so much
different from what could be done just a
few decades later
would it be nearly as surprising to
learn that charlie chaplin
lived long enough to watch star wars
when i was in high school i saw 2001's
pipe dream
for the first time and it blew my mind
my friends and i honestly believed that
it was a real thing
someone had built but recently
i looked it up on youtube and i was like
this is
clearly a computer animation what the
heck was wrong with us
and what do you know the top comment was
exactly that sentiment
our perception of the past is constantly
evolving
as technology does and that's
significant
we don't just think about the past we
also
think about the past the material
properties of an artifact can influence
our relationship with what came before
and push it further away faded yellowy
color
sepia sd pixelated video technological
features can make the past
seem like it was never as real as the
present
but some kinds of evidence collapsed
that chronocentric divide
one way they can do it right now is by
being demotic
ordinary personal candid such recordings
are much more similar to the media we
exchange with each other right now in
the present
this footage of people goofing around in
a 7-eleven in 1987
has more than 6 million views not just
because of nostalgia
but because it's like visiting past
people in their natural habitat
at a time zoo this isn't some pageant
with timeless ambitions
it's a view out the window of a time
machine they don't know is there
another way evidence can corrode
chronocentric illusions is by containing
a convention
more normal than we expect people in old
photos look like
serious robots because back then you had
to stay
in the same pose for a long time to get
a picture taken but also
a long-standing trope in the world of
images up to that point
was that smiling or looking goofy wasn't
a sign of happiness
but of drunkenness or stupidity but
every so often this image pops up online
and people vehemently debate whether
it's actually old or not
sure it's black and white but the
expression seems
too normal to really be on a person from
the past
it is however actually an honest to gosh
picture taken in the early 1900s
one of the earliest known photographs of
a human smiling in fact
the juxtaposition of an expression
someone today might make
with a medium that suggests a technology
of the past
creates an opportunity for chronosaunder
the subject
is both dead and undead
gone but not as unrelatably far as we
may have thought the past was
finally the chronocentric divide can
fade when we find the past captured in a
medium
that was rare at the time but more
common now
this is footage taken by an early hd
camera of new york city
in 1993. it's pretty cool but there's
something almost uncanny about it
watching it isn't exactly like time
traveling back to 1993 but
it looks more like video taken today
than many of us expect
it's like peering through a telescope we
can see them but they can't see us
they appear closer more actual than
usual
we lean in to get grasps of what it was
like
that's part of the allure of time travel
as lp hartley said
the past is a foreign country they do
things differently there
but it hasn't always been that way
time travel wasn't a common feature of
fiction until the 19th century
not because people hadn't thought of it
before they had but
the past and future weren't rich with
interesting destinations
in the same way they are to us now
in the year 1008 it wasn't an insult to
call someone
1000 and late one thousand years ago
the culture and technology around you
was unlikely to be foreign to your
parents
or grandparents or great-grandparents
and outside of an act of god or
gods you didn't expect them to be
foreign to your children or their
children
either one thousand years ago there were
no
80s parties because the 980s weren't
interestingly different pre-modern
societies viewed the present
as a continuation of the past changes
were interpreted as temporary
disturbances of the natural state
but today we see the present as
something special
change is significant enough and rapid
enough now that we would imagine
ourselves quite differently had we been
born
10 years earlier or later zachary sarah
schiffman points out
we failed to realize that people before
the 18th century did not see themselves
this way
instead of having a history they
regarded themselves as having an
unchanging nature
or essence whose full realization might
be impeded or
impelled but not otherwise shaped by
events
nostalgia existed but for moments and
places gone
simply because they were prior to or
away from
here and now not because they were
fundamentally different
and categorically irretrievable as the
discovery of antiquities
and new worlds and new species
accelerated
as the invention of new technologies and
new ways of recording accelerated
the present became less and less like
the past
reinhardt caselk has argued that between
and 1850 the acceleration of history
reached a speed at which
static or cyclical views of time had to
be replaced
with our modern view which understands
the past to be essentially different
from the present
it used to be that things passed now
there is a past as technological
and social change accelerate the window
of time within which things can be
trusted to remain stable
shrinks in such a world to stand still
is scary hartman rosa observed the
pre-modern experience
of being excluded is replaced in
modernity
by the constantly present fear-inducing
possibility
of becoming excluded in the sense
of getting left behind things
change faster and faster and we keep
keeping up
because we are afraid to die whoever
lives twice as fast
can realize twice as many worldly
possibilities and thus as it were
live two lives in the span of one
whoever becomes
infinitely fast no longer needs to fear
death
the annihilator of options acceleration
becomes a secular substitute
for eternity to achieve this salvation
we try to make things
faster and easier to save time but one
of the greatest hoodwinks we ever pulled
on ourselves
was not noticing that the things we do
to save time
leave us with less of it and more alone
in it
no technological change is only
technological
the car allowed people to travel more
quickly and whenever they wanted
but once available it meant people could
live further from where they worked
so cities and towns changed personal
associations
changed roads divided neighborhoods
created new opportunities
while ending others jobs and industries
and cultural forms of expression and a
whole different society sprang into
existence
simply because we found a way to move
faster
likewise smartphones and the internet
made information access
and communication easier and faster but
that's not all they did
along with them came new social
conventions new communities
new levels of exposure to ideas and
conflict a new
understanding of what it meant to be
available that's a lot to have to adapt
to
they even redefined what now is made of
digital spaces are filled with not just
what's being said
but also what has been said and it's all
right there not tucked into a library
across town or
on a tiny plaque on a statue covered in
bird poop it's
in our hands and outside of time
things used to acquire signs of age
veneers that tucked them appropriately
into their place in time
now they're automatically updated to
always look like now
digital spaces are so packed with
timeless messages between bygone people
that we don't even ask is anyone here
anymore
instead we ask is anyone now
in order to adapt to all of this we have
to consume information in an
increasingly dehumanized
decontextualized and decentralized way
each next bit
is often unrelated to the last our
participation is not acknowledged or
assumed
and it's all fed to us by machines we
don't know and didn't build
that only put it in our eyes and ears
the sheer weight of all of this
accreting information and its growing
accessibility
is awe-inspiring it may even be
our purpose i mean what else produces
such detailed records
purposefully or not we record save
collect organize and preserve events
like nothing
else in the universe i've said before
that if humans were to go extinct
the sun would still shine the universe
would keep expanding
jupiter would continue being gassy but
the universe would lose its best
autobiographer
but the technologies of this project
have yet to address
our bodies enter the tv paradox
remember the short long and long short
patterns of time
well a new pattern has been emerging and
growing in frequency
short short it was first observed in
people watching tv alone
they reported feeling like time flew by
quickly
oh wow have i really been watching for
four hours
but later they didn't remember their tv
session as a major moment of significant
import or duration they didn't attend
the passing of time
during it they didn't feel bored or like
time dragged but they also didn't
accumulate a lot of new significant
memory-worthy experiences rapid
stimulating streams of experience
provide a fullness that makes time fly
by
but fractured decentralized one-way
experiences
feel unconnected to ourselves and our
larger life histories retrospectively
they don't fill up a lot of space they
burn our time
on both ends it feels shorter during and
after interestingly short short has not
been found when people engage with
content they have
connections with for example things they
own memorabilia of
made friendships through attended
conventions about
so the pace of life may be taking your
life from you
but standing could give you your life
back
in the future we will surely find other
ways to overcome the negative side
effects of the faster experiences we
crave the development of digital media
that
engage the other senses more linked as
they are with long-term memory
or that build contexts for us could help
so could surgical solutions like
removing the parts of the brain that
make us not like doom scrolling
probably first any anxieties will be
recognized as a condition
treatable with medication now this is
all to say that we live
in a transitional period the conquest of
space made the world
smaller and now the conquest of time
has made our lives smaller we live after
the conquering of time
but before its resurrection in the
meantime
make some time for time to control you
be bored miss out fall behind
feel time passing lose track of time
while experiencing only what your body
can alone
you might not have the time of your life
but you'll have more time
of your life i'll see you next time
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
a great way to engage all of your senses
is a subscription to our
curiosity box a seasonal delivery of
viral physics toys puzzles books games
all curated and cooked up
by us our winter box comes with a
kinetic
torus knot a device for creating
electricity out of produce
try bananas and lots more
our mission at the curiosity box is to
be good for
all brains so we donate a portion of all
proceeds to alzheimer's research
and our inquisitive fellowship which
just gives money
and resources to educational creators so
they can make the kinds of videos
they want to make do your brain a favor
and sign up today
i'm really proud of it i appreciate all
of your support and as always
thanks for watching